lil nass x who is that satanist
homosexual rap singer
the one who who did the whole video
twerking on
on satan's face and because he came out
of the closet
as not not only he came out of the
closet as gay he also came out of the
closet as a satanist selling shoes with
human blood in them
you know that that's not good that's
that's not good at all
he he showed up to an award show wearing
a big dress
that compared the catholic church to the
nazis
he showed up to the 2021 bet awards on
sunday
with a dress that said deus land which
was a reference to deutschland but it
was deus land and had kind of nazi
imagery
on it
some somebody brought up school prayer
on the show the other day and i said
or they brought it up actually on
twitter and i said i'm i'm in favor of
school prayer and someone said well yeah
well should we have a what if i want to
have a prayer to satan would you support
that and i said no i would not support
that but i would support a prayer to god
and they said to me well how can you
support
a prayer to god at school in the morning
like we had in this country for most of
its history until the 1960s
how can you support a prayer to god in
schools but
but then say we can't have a prayer to
satan and
my answer is because god and satan are
different
they're they're very different things
well what what if
my god is satan well then you're in
trouble buster
you better stop that that's not good but
what
but but come on you know it's like
they're both
um uh supernatural
uh uh beings
okay yeah sure but they're different
just like natural beings can be
different
this microphone is different than this
leftist year's tumbler we can make
distinctions and i
i'm not just talking here about little
nas acts or the
school prayer you see this really with
david french's
argument on drag queen story hour he
says that if if we
can't tell perverts that they can't work
for kids in the library then
then they might tell us that we can't go
to church on sunday which frankly
they're already doing
and they've been doing for a year and a
half and and
which by the way if we
if we cannot state that drag queen story
hour
is different and worse than going to
church on sunday
we can't govern ourselves
self-government requires that we have
faculties of reason and moral conscience
if we don't have that if we actually
can't tell the difference
between drag queen story hour and church
on sunday if we can't tell the
difference
between god and satan then we can't tell
the difference between good and bad and
right and wrong and true and false and
so we've got to give up self-government
which increasingly we're doing to the
pouches of the world
and that's too bad that's really really
too bad i like self-government
i like our constitutional system i want
to keep it
science is dead and we have killed it
that's the name of this episode you like
that clip go check out the whole episode
here on youtube you can subscribe you
can like you can go check it out on
apple podcast spotify google play and
stitcher and you can order
my number one nationally best-selling
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds this was number one
top of the nonfiction charts last week
thanks to you so glad people are
engaging with the book hope you like it
as well
we'll see you next time